what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar and i am back at it again to
discuss the mind-blowing chapter of one
piece where we finally get to see
kaido's son
it feels like we've waited so long for
this and it's finally here so make sure
to stay tuned for that
if you enjoy seeing these one piece
chapter reviews and want to keep them
coming show one piece some love by
turning that like button blue
if you haven't be sure to subscribe if
this is crucial hit that notification
bell or you will miss future one piece
videos
it looks like one piece will be on break
next week but in the meantime you can
check out my one piece playlist with
videos about the yonko warlords
supernovas and more
link in the description keep in mind
there will be manga spoilers in this
video we are talking about the latest
chapter chapter 983 after all
now without further ado let's jump into
it this chapter is called thunder so we
may well guess
that something's going to go down in
this one thunder is hype because it's
associated with great power and even
gods like
zeus who is called the thunder god and
like ac dc
we may well assume that somebody's gonna
get thunderstruck in this one we start
with a view
of the waterfall and then we see pero
sparrow
approaching oneegashima using his candy
powers to ride atop the waves
looks like he was sort of ready after
what happened last time with king and
figure out a way to get to anigashima no
matter what
props to him and i also love to see how
creative these devil fruit powers can
get
it seems like aokiji pero sparrow can
avoid falling
into the sea with the help of his powers
perospero can simply use
candy to create a platform he can ride
in this way he's coming and he has it
out for king luffy and marco
three pretty terrifying dudes to face
and yet perospero is committed to taking
them down
which is pretty impressive obviously i
don't want him to succeed but i can
appreciate the guts he's showing here
he reaffirms that he's not cool with the
alliance with the beast pirates and that
as far as he's concerned
the big mom pirates will be the only
ones left standing at the end of the day
big words indeed and this throws another
hype factor into the mix that we can
look forward to
it's awesome that at the end of the day
even if it seems like luffy has to take
down two yonko and their crews the two
crews are clearly not a unified front
and they may well work to weaken each
other rather than fortify each other
we'll also have to wait and see how many
big mom pirates actually end up making
it to the fight before it's over we jump
to ushop and chopper who let us know
that big mom is not after them right now
but after nami and the others
remember there's also prometheus who's
calling big mom after he's found zeus
with nami
on the bright side usap and chopper did
succeed in allowing kinemon and his men
to proceed without being caught
and they're not too worried about nami's
group because they at least have sanji
with them but on second thought can you
really count on sanji in a brothel
we jump into the brothel and big mom is
pretty relaxed since her prey
is heading for the stage she considers
them cornered and believes that there's
no way out for them
as if having a yonko chasing you and a
floating son telling her where you're at
isn't bad enough sanji isn't with them
as expected in the brothel
sanji got sidetracked so our ladies are
on their own
as of now they're trying to rescue
momonosuke who's supposed to be executed
any second in front of everyone and they
have to do that while being chased by
yonko
now that's mission impossible big mom
starts animating objects with her powers
and tells him to follow her
she's getting ready to shake things up
we then jump to poor momonosuke who's
beaten up and tied up on the main stage
for everyone to see momonosuke is around
8 years old so you can bet that this
whole experience if he survives and he
probably shall
will definitely toughen him up and make
him a stronger leader orochi is giving a
speech
and oda really does a good job of making
him hateable through his facial
expressions as well as his actions
he's taking so much messed up joy in
telling everybody that he's about to
execute the helpless son of kozuki odin
things are picking up pace as we keep
jumping from person to person
zorro has to deal with a bunch of
gifters who try convincing him to join
kaido
they let him know that they all wanted
to be pirate king at some point but they
all saw kaido's might and kneel before
him we're constantly getting these
people who try to impose limitations on
our characters
but as we go on in the series the
limitations or ceiling is getting higher
and higher you can bet that luffy is
eventually going to break through every
ceiling but it's interesting how this
keeps popping up in different ways
as the story goes on at first people
tried to stop luffy from being a pirate
then from going to the grand line
and now they're cool with him being a
pirate and in the grand line but they're
telling him that he can't beat a yonko
at almost every stage with no matter
what you do it seems that people will
keep telling you that you can't make it
to the next stage
and some people like a poo give up and
get stuck
at some point in contrast luffy seems
like he'd rather die than stop chasing
his dream of being the pirate king
and you can't help but be inspired by
his unwavering commitment
back to the chapter and captain kit and
killer
also got their hands full killer is
telling kid how crazy it was
for them to try to break through the
front lines but kids just worried about
the rest of his crew not getting found
out
otherwise he confidently says that
they'll manage another manly attitude
that i respect
it's not about what you bear it's about
how you bear it
and kid is dealing with this situation
like a champ
and then when the beast's pirate
opponents are told that kaido is
searching for someone
they drop their guard and kit
immediately takes advantage of that
so much for their promotion it's clear
that word generation titles don't have
anywhere close to the same effect on
pirates as yonko titles do
since so many people seem to
underestimate them and think that they
can take them out
i look forward to seeing if their
reputation grows among pirates after
this fight is over
we finally get to luffy's location and
that was the big meetup last chapter
the one between him and ulti and page
one ulti is being as overprotective of
page one as ever and blames luffy for
hurting him but luffy
rightly points out that she rode page
one like a sled down the stairs it's
kind of like when zoro called out luffy
for causing a scene after cutting down a
building
at first ulti thinks luffy might be some
random beast pirate underling
but then the bystanders let her know
that he's actually an intruder
and luffy being as straightforward as
always straight up tells her
i'm luffy the man who will become king
of the pirates
i love that luffy says stuff like that
in the middle of the beast pirates
not even putting himself on the same
level as yonko kaido
but putting himself above him ulti's not
having it though
despite how rude she can be she's loyal
and says that kaido will be the pirate
king
she goes to headbutt luffy expecting to
crush him and we see the kind of shock
waves you see
when two conquerors hockey users clash
suggesting that one of the flying six
has conquerors haki
too this builds up kaido's crew even
more the shock waves cause massive
damage leaving a hole in the floor
people think luffy is done but page 1
and ulti immediately recognize luffy's
power
and that they have to take him seriously
from the get-go they transform and we
see ulti's fruit is the dragon dragon
fruit ancient model
pachycephalosaurus aka a dinosaur known
for its thick skull
so it makes sense that ulti would start
things off with a headbutt
people wonder why page one and ulti
would use devil fruit powers against
luffy but the two flying six members
sense his haki and acknowledge his skill
luffy admits that he also underestimated
ulti's power and rushes in
he takes her by the horns and slams her
against the ground
then luffy gives page one's dinosaur
form an amazing uppercut using elephant
gun
finally we get to see luffy kicking some
butt after having to run away from apu
but it's short-lived ulti in her
dinosaur form
holds down luffy luffy is impressed by
her strength and ulti is about to hit
him with a strong headbutt
luffy is about to use gear 4 when a dude
one shots ulti
kind of exactly how kaido one shot luffy
the move is called thunderbagwa
and again we get what look like conquer
hockey shockwaves
so clearly the thunder in the chapter
title was referring to this
beast and ulti just got thunder struck
here some people might be upset that
luffy was appearing to lose to ulti but
oda purposely pointed out that despite
having to take on page 1 and ulti on his
own
luffy was not beat and was about to use
gear 4
but he was saved from having to use it
by this masked man ulti's power was
hyped up big time but
only to hype up this masked beast even
more who turns out to be yamato
kaido's son we finally see yamato and
what an introduction
i was expecting to see a longer fight
between luffy and ulti but yamato coming
in like this was epic
and what's even more epic he took
luffy's side
he has broken handcuffs on his wrists
suggesting that he was being kept
prisoner so ironically kaido's son might
be the key to helping beat kaido himself
if anyone knows his weaknesses it's
probably his son and he clearly has
immense power we were not wrong to
assume that he'd be
op while others are screaming out that
kaido wants yamato captured luffy and
yamato have a talk
kaido's son picks up luffy and tells him
he's not going to hurt him as he runs
away from all the beast pirates chasing
him yamato says he's been waiting for
luffy and in the corner it reads friend
or foe
wow we definitely had more happen in
this chapter than i expected i love how
ulti was giving luffy
trouble and showing off her power and
then yamato comes
in and just one-shots her and he saved
luffy from using gear 4 so early on
which is good if luffy is thinking of
using gear 4 versus the flying six
members then he's definitely gonna have
to unlock
gear 5 for kaido but this is so
interesting right now
the idea of yamato helping luffy was
mentioned by some of you in the comments
and it's hype aaf that it appears to
have worked out like that i was not
disappointed by his power
and now we have another heavy hitter pun
intended to join the cause with pero
sparrow not especially liking the beast
pirates 2
inner conflict brewing sasuke ulti and
page 1 potentially all taken out already
taking down a yonko crew is starting to
seem more and more possible oda is
definitely filling out a road map to
victory
more and more each chapter we still
gotta save momonosuke and hope that
nami's fine looking self not only
survives big mom
but also hopefully keeps zeus and maybe
even gets prometheus
although i know that would be a lot to
ask for and thank you oda for that
beautiful elephant gun uppercut to page
one that was definitely a page turner
you don't get to see such clean and
satisfying hits often as always let me
know what you expect or would like to
see in the upcoming chapters yamato
definitely seems like a friend now
but how much can we trust ayonko's son
one thing's for sure though
things are just getting crazier and
crazier right now if you did enjoy this
video and want to keep them coming show
one piece some love by smashing that
like button
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial ring that notification
bell or you will miss future one piece
videos
and as you're waiting two weeks for the
next chapter to come out check out my
one piece playlist link in the
description
and suggest more one piece videos you're
dying to see
in the comments lastly the youtube ad
rates have significantly dropped
recently
so the help and support we're getting
from our anime opera patrons is now more
important than ever
a very special thank you goes out to our
patrons over on patreon who help us
survive these youtube issues and who
helped make videos like this one
possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
legend acknowledged by lord twigo
himself
efren a and the one tier patrons the
ones who stand atop
all clans stephen and grotta alola and
atem the world steelers acquire respect
but they have a jonathan king
decide brandon of isles papa smurf the
school bus
king riser emperor otaku richie martinez
and thomas jones
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh nothing but a fan
jason wilson kings out just anatoly
kazatsky angel cruz cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci alicia actor
jessica kayla fond hinokami and water
bonnie park zodiar12 rathu and deora
tien huang
cynical kraken fulgus 77 and deadly
saints
thank you all so much if you enjoy our
work you can support more of it by going
over to patreon.com
anime pro and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar if you do
soil gear name featured in future videos
alongside these
amazing people right here and you'll
even get access to our private patron
only discord where we talk about anime
life and of course dank memes so check
out patreon.com
anime outpour link in the description if
you're interested you can also now join
the youtube channel and support more
content that way if you prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you